super bowl 53 mvp julian edelman has
embarked on a media tour in support of a
documentary that debuts on friday he did
a full hour town hall with sirius xm nfl
radio on
tuesday and he discussed among other
things his ped suspension from last year
he said it was a low time you're already
batting battling mentally if you can do
it like you did it this is after his acl
tear in 2017 then all of a sudden you
have this you're dealing with this
you're dealing with everyone outside of
your life and what people are saying and
dealing with and you can't really get
too involved into it because you're
ultimately trying to get yourself back
to playing football it was honestly
probably the toughest time of my life at
that point and you know the one thing he
said there you're already battling
mentally if you can do it like you did
it that's where that temptation arises
chris a guy coming off of an injury
right trying to get himself back to 100
there's that ped
you're going to justify the opportunity
to compete with yourself and with
everyone else out there to get yourself
healthy you tell yourself other people
are doing the same thing and you also
tell yourself if i get caught look it's
worth the risk because otherwise i'm not
going to get to the level of health that
i need to get to yeah that i mean yes
that certainly seems to be an argument
that goes on you know in the brain of
players i i do you know and i don't
condone it definitely and you know the
first thing is
hey i mean
this this is it's a bad example for
everybody kids coming up who are trying
to be athletes i mean we're talking
about cheating and it makes me question
everything about julian edelman because
he did get busted that way you know i
want to like julian edelman he's a cool
guy and damn he's played a lot of good
football but ever since the positive ped
test it's made me question his whole
career from that standpoint now i do
think the question of like and i am
totally against performance enhancing
drugs
but i'll say this to add to your other
twitter question you have out there and
everything like that
i do wish there was a way the nfl could
find a way to help guys who have torn
their achilles tendon or their acl or
patella attendant to where if there is
performance enhancing drugs that are out
there that will help you know improve
the recovery process and make everything
heal better i wish the nfl could find a
way where they can monitor a guy through
that time period to where okay you can
take it till you get healthy and then
okay now we think you're healthy enough
you got to get off it and go back to now
they can negotiate it the nfl nfl pa can
negotiate that right an exception to the
ped policy that allows certain
performance enhancing drugs to be used
to help guys who are recovering from
certain specific
serious injuries and that's easy and
until that happens there is no exception
we've got the two poll questions one do
you care if a player including a guy
like julian edelman patrick peterson or
anyone else is caught using peds 53
say no i guess i'm not surprised but
it's a little depressing that people
don't care that that many people do not
care and and that's the and this is what
drives baseball fans crazy because
people care about it a lot more in
baseball than they do in football i
think part of it is we look at these
guys they're gladiators how are they
going to get that big how are they going
to stay that big how do they recover
from their injuries yeah yeah they're
going to have some pharmaceutical
enhancement more than half of the fans
seem to be okay with that chris yeah no
i know i know and that that does bother
me and and i i also think there's you
know
yeah i i mean i just don't get that gosh
i don't want cheating is it's unfair and
i do care and gosh the guys that are not
cheating it's totally unfair to them and
you're putting them in harm's way by
they're doing it naturally and now
there's another guy who's six four two
seventy but he's on peds and now he's
six four two ninety and he's faster and
stronger than he was at 270 and he's
running into you know so that's it's a
health risk at you know factor in this
conversation as well and i'm just amazed
but mike here's the big thing with me
and i have this argument i've had this
argument with my dad and i've had it
with a lot of people like well i what is
that what do how what how many people do
you think in the locker room are taking
performance enhancing drugs like i'm a
guy that i go i think it's a handful of
guys on a 53-man roster where i go yeah
maybe it's four to seven guys in a
locker room i know like my father and
other players i've talked to they go oh
you're crazy you're being way too nice
it's it's more like it's 40 or it's 30
out of 53 guys i don't know maybe i'm
you know
gullible that way but i got a question
what's your feeling i got a question for
you okay go ahead i got a question for
you when you were recovering from the
loss of your spleen and dealing with
proprioception that problem where your
body doesn't relate to the surroundings
right it was hard you had to re-learn
how to throw right if there was a ped
you could have taken that would have
cured that forever would you have taken
it yeah i i i guess i would have yes you
know i would have done it i would have
tried to have done it ethically i feel
like i mean yeah that would no no that's
what you're saying if it's a lie
no i would not
band substance no here it is absolutely
just just just take this pill and you'll
be fi you'll be the guy you were before
you lost your spleen but this is a
banned substance under the nfl's ped
policy would you have taken no i would
not have there's no way and hey listen
there was things like hgh that were out
there at that time when i was already
going through it and people talking
about that help healing yeah there's no
freaking way i would do that i'd never
be able to even even if even if the
percentage of other guys taking it is
much higher than you think like if you
look around and say half these guys are
on something
even then you wouldn't do it i no i i
don't feel like i would why wouldn't you
do it because i just feel like i'd be
cheating myself and cheating other
people and i just don't think i would be
able to deal with it i mean like live
with it my conscience would feel guilty
and and i just that's just not my style
i'm so adamant against it but i do
wonder how many guys are really on pd's
in a locker room in the nfl i think it's
more than you think yeah maybe i'm wrong
they're not waving it around we got a
good draft coming up right here on pft
live we'll be back with more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports